would you in that context if morpheus
came to you
would you take the blue pill or the red
pill
meaning would you be happy just living
in that world and not knowing that
you're living inside that virtual world
that's running a computer
or would you want to know the truth of
it well actually
i think that's a very different question
right there's a there's a there's a
actually moral ethical question there
about whether you should allow a bunch
of people to get you know manipulated
and killed and enslaved
because in the matrix they're all
enslaved and as as as
as like you know a triple a battery to
turn a human being into the battery
right
um so i i think the
the moral and ethical question of that
fascinating enough isn't actually
different than the more unethical
questions we face today
in modern daily life but i
probably have given the choice of just
completely going along or
going against it i would probably go
against it
if i had to make this kind of binary
choice because going
going along with it
i think at that scale of scary you know
stuff happening to people
is is probably something really really
really difficult
but for your individual life it's way
more fun to go along with it
so you're saying you value
the opposing a system that includes
the suffering of others versus just for
yourself and
enjoying the ride i mean what what's
what's if there is such a binary choice
why choose the opposite system i think
it's the nature of um kind of the
ethical dilemma that you face in that
situation
there's kind of some you know this is
obviously not something that's happening
now right
we don't know this right
at the end of the day at that scale
of of something like that happening yeah
that scale
of of people being um you know
manipulated and harmed
then i think pretty much almost all
people have an obligation
to go to go against it uh
probably that's what that that looks
like in my opinion
you